[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live stellen wir uns mal vor du bist so
erschöpft dass du das Haus nicht mehr
verlassen kannst dass du kaum mehr
schlafen kannst dass an Arbeiten ein
soziales Leben kaum mehr zu denken ist
so geht es vielen Menschen die an mecfs
leiden dem chronischen
Erschöpfungssyndrom die Zahl der
Erkrankten ist mit der corona-pandemie
noch mal gestiegen so dass man
inzwischen von einer halbe Million mehr
als eine halbe Million Betroffenen in
Deutschland ausgeht und trotzdem sie
sagen auch wenn sie inzwischen so viel
mehr erkrankte sind es fehlt an
Versorgung es fehlt an Aufmerksamkeit es
fehlt an Forschung im Stich gelassen mit
Erschöpfung sind Syndrom deshalb heute
bei uns Thema denn in Berlin sind heute
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen für
mehr Aufmerksamkeit für die Erkrankung
sie zogen vom Alexanderplatz zum Roten
Rathaus sie nannten ist ein Trauer Gang
wollen an alle erinnern die zu Hause
unversorgt in ihren Betten liegen und
Solidaritäten mit ihnen zeigen lernt
heute mehr mit uns über die Krankheit in
dieser Sendung im Stream diskutiert mit
und stellt gerne Fragen direkt bei
Youtube Facebook oder eben auch per Mail
bei uns ist jetzt zugeschaltet die
Initiatoren des Protest der
Demonstration heute Grit bogenhagen
selbst an macfs erkrankt und nun
zugeschaltet hallo schönen guten Tag
Frau Bugenhagen ja schönen guten Abend
sie sind leider schon weit vor der
corona-pandemie erkrankt schon 2001 und
für alle die diese Krankheit noch nicht
kennen würde ich sie direkt am Anfang
noch mal fragen wie äußert sich das
konkret bei Ihnen
also bei mir hat es 2001 angefangen ich
hatte eine sehr schwere Grippe die sich
über mehrere Monate hinweggezogen hat
und dann ganz langsam
nur zu Ende gegangen ist bzw so richtig
zu Ende gegangen ist sie nie ich konnte
dann wieder arbeiten aber ich hatte
nicht mehr die Kraft die ich vorher
hatte nicht mehr die Energie die ich
vorher hatte ich habe das dann gemerkt
dass ich
schneller schneller war erschöpfbar war
als früher dass ich deutlich mehr
Schmerzen hatte als früher das hat sich
bei mir vor allen Dingen in Migräne
gezeigt dass ich also in der Woche bis
zu drei vier Mal Migräne hatte
das hat sich in Reizdarm
reizblase-syndrom gezeigt und
Muskelschmerzen
und das habe ich aber alles abgetan weil
irgendwie konnte ich noch funktionieren
ich konnte noch arbeiten und bin dann
eben auch noch arbeiten gegangen
wir haben auch Bilder sie haben uns
Bilder zur Verfügung gestellt Bilder von
damals als sie noch gesund waren Bilder
von heute jetzt wo einfach so vieles
nicht mehr geht und inzwischen ist es
auch so schon seit einigen Jahren dass
sie auch nicht mehr arbeiten können
richtig
genau seit 2013 bin ich leider
arbeitsunfähig genau und ich hatte das
eingangs gesagt wie ihnen geht es so
vermuten inzwischen viele einfach schon
eine halbe Million Menschen in
Deutschland und es gibt einen Beitrag
den die Kollegin Susanna Santina und
Carsten heckes für uns zusammengefasst
hat da geht es eben um sie und auch noch
um andere Betroffene wir schauen kurz
zusammen rein
seit Januar ist Angela Müller ins Bett
gefesselt die 48-Jährige hat er mir CFS
eine schwere neuroimmunologische
Erkrankung die bei ihr vor einigen
Jahren wohl durch die Infektion mit
mehreren Viren ausbrach seit sechs
Monaten liegt Sie 24 Stunden am Tag im
Bett
Lärm ist ganz schlimm wenn ein Gespräch
ist werden Geräusche sind das ist es
macht sofort Schmerzen bei mir das
schlimmste an der Krankheit ist dass die
Anwesenheit von anderen Menschen mein
Zustand verschlechtert wenn ich meine
eigenen Kinder nicht mehr ertragen kann
das ist das Schlimmste bevor die Mutter
von zwei erwachsenen Kindern so schwer
erkrankte war sehr ein erfolgreiche
bio-bäuerin die agraringenieurin führte
mit ihrem Mann einen Hof Martin ist ihre
große Stütze hilft dir z.B wenn sie auf
Toilette oder Duschen geht sonst fühlt
sie sich im Stich gelassen kein einziges
Medikament nämlich kriege ich selbst
recherchiert hätte jegliche medizinische
Beratung läuft über Selbsthilfegruppen
es ist alles eigene Recherche wir müssen
medizinische Studien lesen ohne Ende bis
heute ist mcfs nicht heilbar
viel eigene Recherche die es da braucht
wieso dauert der Weg bis zur Diagnose so
lange und geht das ihnen auch oder ging
das ihnen auch genauso dass sie bis
heute einfach schauen müssen selbst
schauen müssen wie sie sich selbst
helfen können
genau also meine Diagnose bekam ich erst
2018 durch die Charité durch das
fertigzentrum dort vorher wusste ich
nicht woran ich leide ich bin durch
viele viele Psychiatrien gegangen habe
sehr sehr viel Psychotherapie gemacht
habe auch sehr viel gelernt dabei das
war also nicht alles schlecht aber die
Erkrankung ist nicht besser geworden ich
hatte nicht mehr Kraft ich hatte nicht
mehr
Energie die Schmerzen haben nicht
aufgehört diese
Migräneanfälle haben nicht aufgehört und
der Verlauf war eben schleichend aber
fortschreitend so dass ich eben ab 2018
ab 2013 nicht mehr arbeiten konnte und
ab 2018 sogar weitgehend ans Bett
gebunden war
gibt es etwas was Ihnen überhaupt hilft
heute
ja mir hilft es ganz ganz streng zu
passen auf meine Belastungsgrenzen zu
achten und niemals darüber hinweg zu
gehen
was heißt können Sie das für uns auch ja
pelsen heißt also wir merken wann unsere
Kraft zu Ende ist
und über diesen Punkt wann der zu Ende
ist darf man niemals drüber weggehen man
soll also gar am besten vorher aufhören
eventuell sogar ein Tagebuch für dass
man merkt wo ist dieser Punkt wo ist
dann zu viel wird und wenn man über
diesen Punkt geht dann bekommt man auch
die Quittung dann bekommt man diesen
Crash eine zustandsverschlechterung nach
eben dieser Überanstrengung
sie haben einen Verein gegründet weil
sie sagen es fehlt ein pflegerischer
Versorgung in Deutschland was läuft
schief konkret bei uns und was tut ihr
für einen dagegen
die Versorgung findet einfach gar nicht
statt die Leute die ähm bekommen weil es
eben keine Diagnostik gibt für ecfs
bekommen die Leute keine kein Pflegegrad
sie bekommen keinen Grad der Behinderung
sie bekommen kein Rollstuhl sie bekommen
einfach nichts von unserem sozialen
System und da liegt genau das Problem
weil wenn sie nichts bekommen müssen sie
sich auch wieder ständig überanstrengen
und verschlechtern ihre Situation
das geht dann soweit dass wenn jemand im
Crash ist also wenn wenn dieser Kreis
Übereinkommen der kommt nicht also
selten schleichend der kommt meistens
plötzlich also bei mir ist es dann zum
Beispiel so gewesen ich habe mich
hingelegt dann kam der Crash und dann
konnte ich mich drei vier Tage nicht
mehr bewegen
andere merken wenn er kommt bei anderen
ist es wiederum so dass die morgens früh
oft am Morgen früh auf einmal nicht mehr
aufstehen können und merken dann ist
dieser Crash da und können sich nicht
mehr bewegen und in diesem Kreis braucht
man dringend Hilfe wenn man keine
Familie hat braucht man Hilfe
und die ist momentan nicht gegeben und
in einem dieser Kreis wo ich keine Hilfe
bekommen habe habe ich gesagt dann muss
ich eben die Hilfe organisieren was es
nicht gibt muss eben gemacht werden
damit es das gibt
und hatte diese Idee mit diesem Verein
und habe Leute gesucht Menschen gesucht
die mit mir diese Idee diese Vision von
einem Verein der Erste Hilfe leistet im
Crash der aber auch die Leute den Leuten
hilft
in die sozialen Netze reinzukommen also
zum Beispiel dass der Verein
Sozialarbeiter einstellt diese
Sozialarbeiter helfen den Leuten Anträge
auszufüllen was für sie alleine nicht
mehr in der Lage sind ja da kommen die
Sozialarbeiter helfen den Leuten die
Anträge auszufüllen und dann bekommen
die Leute eventuell mit ein bisschen
Glück ein Pflegegrad der Behinderung
aber auch ein betreutes Einzelwohnen wo
dann Sozialarbeiter regelmäßig hingeht
diese Lücke zwischen nicht Versorgung
und sozialen Netz die ein Betroffener
alleine nicht überwältigen kann zu
füllen ist die vordergründige Aufgabe
des Vereins me hilfe hilfe einfach ja
Entschuldigung was wir uns vorgenommen
haben gibt es noch nicht also den Verein
gibt es zwar schon aber die Hilfe gibt
es noch nicht also Hilfe einfach auch
dabei ganz den Alltag zu bewerkstelligen
und mit dieser Krankheit klarzukommen es
gibt eine Frage an Sie aus dem Stream
ein User eine Userin nennt sich peace
möchte wissen was würden sich Betroffene
von nicht betroffenen wünschen also
welche Hilfe aus der Gesellschaft
es fängt an bei Arzttermin wenn ich
anrufe bei einem Arzt dass ich dann sage
ich habe eine belastungsintoleranz kann
ich als erste dran kommen dass dann eben
mir geholfen wird dass ich den ersten
Termin morgens Kriege oder nach der
Mittagspause den ersten Termin kriege
wenn ich im Crash bin und zu mir kommt
jemand ins Zimmer dann kann ich keine
Geräusche ertragen kein Licht ertragen
das heißt das Zimmer muss dunkel bleiben
da kann mein Freund Nachbar oder wer
auch immer nicht einfach das Licht
anmachen weil das tut mir weh wenn er
dann versucht mit mir zu sprechen dann
sind das für mich hören Quallen das tut
mir weh das kann ich in dem Moment nicht
aushalten die einzige Kommunikation die
in dem Moment stattfinden kann ist wenn
ich die Kraft habe zum Schreiben ist
geschrieben und es darf eben nur ein
ganz gedämpftes Licht sein
Fenster Türen zu machen damit die
Geräusche nicht von draußen sind ich
habe es erlebt die Waschmaschine von
meiner Obermieterin die läuft eine halbe
Stunde ich leider heulen Qualen in
dieser eine halbe Stunde wenn mir
irgendjemand helfen könnte diese
Waschmaschine auszumachen kann sich kein
Mensch vorstellen was da in einem abgeht
als wenn man drauf sitzt und und jeder
jede Vibration hundertfach verstärkt
wird es tut weh es tut richtig weh und
es zieht einem die Kraft aus dem Körper
und man liegt dann nachher noch
erschöpfter da als in dem Moment wo das
passiert ist die Politik hat mehr Geld
für die Forschung versprochen um 40
Millionen Euro geht es stand jetzt was
fordern ja was fordern Sie konkret wer
meine Frage
das sind 40 Millionen nicht für die
Forschung in dem Sinne sondern für die
also doch für die Forschung ja aber für
die Versorgungsforschung ja da geht's
darum dass geforscht wird wie wir
eventuell versorgt werden könnten und ob
das überhaupt profitabel ist das heißt
für uns
kommt dann kommt er im Moment nichts an
solange diese Forschung nicht beendet
ist und es steht in den Sternen wann die
beendet ist kommt hier aktuell nichts an
wir kriegen keine Versorgung weder
medizinische noch pflegerische es findet
im Moment nichts statt und diese 40
Millionen sind wichtig finden irgendwann
statt bringt uns im Moment aber auch gar
nichts das heißt für die Zukunft wenn
sie noch mal konkret auch die
Forderungen an die Politik formulieren
könnten wie lautet die
wir brauchen mindestens 100 Millionen es
ist eine Summe die nicht genießen mal
aufgeschrieben hat aber die ganz richtig
ist mindestens 100 Millionen in der
medizinischen Forschung die zum Beispiel
eine Frau Professor Carmen scheibenbogen
durchführt die aber auch viele andere
Institutionen in Deutschland durchführt
medizinische Forschung für medizinische
Therapien für evidenzbasierte Medizin
für und
das sagt Grit bogenhagen sie hat den
Verein emmi-hilfe gegründet ist selbst
betroffen und hat eben auch heute die
Liegen Demo in Berlin organisiert vielen
lieben Dank dass Sie sich heute Zeit für
uns genommen haben Grip bogenhagen
danke
und sie hat eben schon angesprochen eine
Professorin die wo wir das Glück haben
die wir heute auch einladen konnten es
ist die Leiterin das vertikzentrums an
der Berliner charités ist Professor Dr
Carmen scheibenbogen eine Expertin eben
in der Beschäftigung mit mecfs und sie
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet hallo schön
guten Tag Frau Professor Dr
scheibenbogen
hallo schönen guten Abend wie groß ist
denn die Nachfrage bei ihnen im
vertikzentrum was ja so in seiner Art
ist nicht allzu häufig gibt in
Deutschland
nun wir haben bei uns eine Sprechstunde
für Patienten die an im ecfs erkrankt
sind und die Nachfrage hat stark
zugenommen was uns auch nicht überrascht
hat wir haben
seit
2020 etwa viermal so viele Patienten die
einen Termin in unserer Sprechstunde
haben möchten und wir haben infolge
dessen leider jetzt lange Wartezeiten
und wir können ja auch noch eine
regionalversorgung anbieten für unsere
Patienten aus Berlin Brandenburg das ist
also auch für uns momentan eine
starke Unterversorgung selbst wenn es
unser Zentrum gibt heißt das ähm dennoch
nicht das ähm Betroffene vor Ort bei uns
alle zeitnahende Diagnose bekommen
können
und für alle die sich noch nicht so gut
mit dem Thema auskennen dass auch noch
mal ein bisschen konkreter zu machen wer
kann denn alles und wie auf welchem Weg
erkranken
gutes Krankheitsbild im ecfs kennen wir
ja schon lange das ist nichts was jetzt
neu infolge der Pandemie aufgetreten ist
das ist eine Erkrankung die meistens
durch eine schwerere Infektion ausgelöst
wird wie wir gerade gehört haben das
kann den Grippe sein bei jüngeren
Menschen ist es häufig eine
sogenannte infektiöse also eine
EBV-Infektion und inzwischen ist der
häufigste Auslöser kovet und es betrifft
viele jüngere Menschen und Frauen sind
sehr viel häufiger betroffen also nach
Kurve sie mir jetzt das ähm vier von
fünf betroffene Frauen sind wir kennen
inzwischen bestimmte Risikofaktoren wir
wissen es sind oft Menschen die in der
Familie
Autoimmunerkrankungen haben wir wissen
es bestimmte immunologische
Risikofaktoren wie das man erstmal
leidet oder Übergewicht hat auch dazu
führen können dass man die Erkrankung
bekommt aber viele Menschen bekommen die
Erkrankungen auch ohne
Risikofaktoren und heißt das jetzt jeder
mit longkonvent hat dann auch im icfs
nein das heißt es nicht also longkow
wird ist ja ein ganz breites Spektrum
unterschiedlicher
Symptome und Erkrankungen lonkovit heißt
ja erstmal nur dass man vier Wochen nach
der Infektion anhaltende Symptome hat
das gute ist es halt bei vielen dann in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten noch aus
aber die schlechte Nachricht ist auch
dass wenn man länger als 6 Monate krank
ist das Risiko auch hoch ist dass man
anhalten krank bleibt und von den
Menschen die an diesem Symptom
vertikleiden und belastungsintoleranz
war so die häufigsten Symptome sind von
longkow wird da ist es so dass etwa die
Hälfte des Krankheitsbild mcfs
entwickelt
es gibt jetzt einige Fragen an sie aus
dem Stream die möchte ich jetzt gerne
hier mit reinnehmen zum einen fragt sich
es wenn unten da bei Facebook wo sind
denn die Unterschiede zu anderen
psychischen Erkrankungen wie Burnout
oder Depressionen sind die Menschen
vielleicht auch hochsensibel
also ich wundere mich ehrlich gesagt
immer dass das so in einem Atemzug mit
mit psychischen Erkrankungen genannt
wird weil im ecfs wird ja mit einer
psychiatrischen Erkrankung wieder
Depression relativ wenig gemeinsam ein
depressiver Mensch der hat ja
typischerweise auch
eine
verminderte
Leistungsfähigkeit also der ist oft gar
nicht mehr ähm interessiert am Alltag
teilzunehmen ähm der ist oft wenig
motiviert und und im ecfs Betroffene
sind ja auf das Gegenteil ich meine dass
man wenn man ähm so schwer krank ist und
so wenig Hoffnung hat auch Heilung und
auch so eine schlechte Versorgung hat
dass man da auch ähm unglücklich mit ist
oder oder dass man ähm soll man da
vielleicht auch manchmal depressiv
werden kann das ist ja für jeden
verständlich aber diese Erkrankungen
sind nicht
und auch longkofe das muss ich noch mal
ganz klar betonen ist in den seltensten
Fällen eine psychische oder
psychosomatische Erkrankung wir haben
heute so viele Evidenzen die ganz klar
zeigen was da durcheinander gekommen ist
wir sehen dass das Immunsystem aktiv ist
wir sehen im dass sie Durchblutung
gestört ist wir sehen bei vielen
Betroffenen das noch virusreste da sind
das betrifft im long koved aber viele
dieser Krankheitsmechanismen betreffen
auch im ecfs und wir können das ja auch
messen also wir sehen ja bei diesem
Krankheitsbild die Menschen haben diese
schwere vertik nicht nur
gefühlt sondern das kann man messen die
haben also ganz oft stark verminderte
Kraft in den Händen wir können diese
diese schweren
Kreislaufstörungen die viele Patienten
haben diese kaum noch aufstehen können
weil ihn dann schwindlich wird die kann
man auch gut messen Stichwort messen da
fragt sich ein User Userin mit dem
Kürzel k.h es wurde von spürbaren
Schmerzen gesprochen kann man nicht die
Hirnaktivität messen und dadurch mehr
herausfinden
nun in der Vergangenheit gab es leider
nicht sehr viele Studien zu mecf es ist
eine Erkrankung die auch von der
Wissenschaft weitgehend
ignoriert wurde das hat sich mit der
Pandemie erfreulicherweise geändert und
in den letzten
zwölf Monaten sind sehr viele Studien
rausgekommen auch im Studien die die
Gehirnfunktion untersucht haben die eine
Vielzahl von Auffälligkeiten gezeigt
haben z.B das ähm das die Durchblutung
des Gehirns vermindert ist Hinweise für
Entzündung aber auch Hinweise dass die
Verbindungen im Gehirn verändert sind
und das wiederum auch mit Symptom
schwere korreliert und mit Biomarkern
für Entzündung so dass ich denke dass
wir da sehr schnell jetzt ähm sehr klare
Konzepte haben werden was das Problem
bei der Erkrankung ist und das ist ja
auch ganz entscheidend denn auf dieser
Grundlage kann man sehr viel besser auch
gezielt Medikamente entwickeln
sie haben selbst auch in einer Studie
mitgearbeitet Veröffentlichungen sagten
sie mir vor dieser Sendung Ende dieser
Woche im lernset-magazin im Fachmagazin
schauen wir auch mal zusammen rein wir
haben uns einen Vorabdruck wenn ich das
so richtig sage geöffnet ich hoffe Sie
können den auch sehen ich habe hier mal
die Seite 20 geöffnet da sehen wir ähm
oder am besten erklären Sie uns das
natürlich also ich würde sagen hier
sehen wir wahrscheinlich jetzt die
ganzen Ausprägungen also was man fühlen
kann die ganzen Symptome die man spürt
oder wie würden Sie uns jetzt diese
Ergebnisse hier erklären ja das ist eine
sehr umfangreiche Tabelle aber was sie
uns sagt ist
dass die Menschen an sehr vielen
unterschiedlichen symptomenleiden das
ist diese lange Liste die wir hier auf
der linken Spalte sehen und was wir dann
im weiteren untersucht haben ist wie
sich das über die Zeit entwickelt wir
haben also drei verschiedene Zeitpunkte
also baseline das ist meistens Monat
sechs und dann haben sich die
Betroffenen bei uns noch mal nach 6
Monaten vorgestellt
und dann noch mal bis zu zwei Jahre
später und
wir sehen dass die Patienten anhaltend
krank sind wenn wir die Diagnose mecfs
stellen mussten das ist so eine der
Hauptaussagen dieser Studie und
die Patienten die also sich bei uns
vorgestellt haben die Waren in der Regel
schon schwerer krank die haben also alle
vertik gehabt belastungsintoleranz und
etwa die Hälfte haben dieses
Krankheitsbild macfs nach diesen
sogenannten Kanada Kriterien und die
sind leider also anhaltend krank über
zwei Jahre und viele auch schwer krank
wir haben auch ähm etwa die Hälfte der
Betroffenen ähm in dieser Studie weiter
untersucht die das Krankheitsbild im
ecfs nicht haben und hier ist die gute
Nachricht das ist vielen von denen über
die Zeit besser geht allerdings auch
nicht allen also viele sind auch nach
zwei Jahren noch krank aber zumindest
sieht man da ähm
heilungs-chancen für viele der
Betroffenen und das das wichtige aber an
dieser Studie jetzt auch für uns ist es
dass wir eben sehen dass wir mit einer
reinen
Symptombehandlung im
ecfs auch wenn wir es früher
diagnostizieren bei den meisten nicht
wesentlich beeinflussen können
wenn wir bei dem Thema jetzt auch
Forschung und der Studienlage bleiben im
icfs wurde von der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation von der WHO
bereits 1969 als neuroimmunologische
Krankheit anerkannt viele Mediziner und
Medizinerinnen müssen trotzdem heute
auch noch nicht allzu viel über das
Krankheitsbild dazu passt jetzt eine
Frage von Claudia mondrowski bei Youtube
sie fragt sich wie ist die
Forschungslage im Ausland ist man auch
mit dem Ausland vernetzt auch
Selbsthilfegruppen im Ausland wie sieht
es da aus hilft das für die Forschung
jetzt die Vernetzung ins Ausland
ja wir sind sehr gut vernetzt wir hatten
schon
2015 eine Förderung von der EU für einen
mecfs-netzwerk eurormin und wir haben
natürlich auch inzwischen sehr gute
Möglichkeiten uns auszutauschen diese
digitalen Techniken führen dazu dass wir
sehr viel mehr auch Tagung machen können
also wir hatten z.B im Mai eine eine
mezf Tagung in Berlin da waren am
Wissenschaftler aus aller Welt
zugeschaltet und wir haben durch diese
sogenannten pre-print-server wo auch
gerade diese Studie von uns gesehen
haben inzwischen auch ein Medium wo
Veröffentlichungen sehr schnell
zugänglich gemacht werden also wir haben
ja normalerweise bei einer
Veröffentlichung so einen langen
Begutachtungsprozess das kann sich über
ein halbes Jahr oder noch länger
hinziehen und das erfolgt weiterhin aber
die Veröffentlichung werden jetzt schon
wenn jetzt also schon vorab
veröffentlicht so dass das sicher auch
noch mal die Forschung deutlich
beschleunigt und wir hatten das eben
schon angesprochen im ersten Teil der
Sendung dass ihm die Bundesregierung ja
auch Geld zur Verfügung stellen möchte
hatten darüber also schon gesprochen was
erhoffen Sie sich also von diesen
Millionen die der Gesundheitsminister
dazu Verfügung stellen möchte
also ich finde das ist erstmal ein guter
Anfang es geht ja hier um 40 Millionen
Euro die für Versorgung in Aussicht
gestellt wurden ein Teil für die
sogenannte Versorgungsforschung da sagte
Frau buchenhaupt völlig zu Recht da muss
man natürlich jetzt schauen dass das
Geld auch möglichst schnell zur
Verfügung steht und nicht nur Daten
erhoben werden sondern dass es bereits
zur Verfügung steht auch um die
Betroffenen zu versorgen das heißt was
wir dringend brauchen sind ähm
Zentren um schnell eine Diagnose zu
stellen um Therapiekonzepte zu erstellen
was ja auch heute ja schon machen können
was wir gerade gehört haben selbst
pacing ist ein
Therapiekonzept was zumindest Symptome
lindern kann und was viele Ärzte noch
gar nicht kennen und dann sind ja noch
mal 20 Millionen Aussicht gestellt von
und ich hoffe sehr dass die auch sehr
schnell am ankommen so dass wir also
auch wirklich
in der Breite mehr Versorgungsstrukturen
haben für Betroffene denn was wir
dringend brauchen ist dass wir so wie es
bei allen anderen schweren Erkrankungen
auch es dass wir Anlaufstellen haben wo
man wenn man erkrankt ist auch rasch
eine Diagnose bekommen kann und ein
Therapiekonzept bekommen kann denn die
Hausärzte sind mit dieser schweren
Erkrankung ja völlig überfordert und
aber weitgehend allein gelassen bis
heute der Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach hatte sich auch vor rund
einem Monat als er das Programm
vorgestellt hat geäußert wir hören mal
kurz rein zusammen in einen Ton sprechen
dann darüber
wenn es uns gelingt die 40 Millionen die
jetzt für versorgungsforschungen
aufgebaut werden wenn es uns gelingt
diese wirklich gut einzusetzen dass wir
gute Projekte haben dann sind wir gut
bedienen und auch gut unterwegs
gute Projekte dann sind wir gut bedient
und gut unterwegs würden sie das auch so
sagen reicht das dann
sag mal so am Ende brauchen wir ja keine
Versorgungsstrukturen neu zu erfinden
sondern wir brauchen einfach nur die
Versorgungsstrukturen die wir auch für
andere im vergleichbarer schwerer und
häufige Erkrankungen haben und da geht
es zum Beispiel darum dass wir dann auch
entsprechende Vergütung von den
Krankenkassen bekommen die wir heute
noch nicht haben und was auch ganz
entscheidend ist wir müssen zunächst mal
auch die Ärzte dazu bekommen sich um
diese Erkrankung zu kümmern denn das
Problem ist stand heute das ist in den
meisten Universitäten gar keine
Anlaufstellen gibt und dass viele Ärzte
sich auch gar nicht mit der Erkrankung
auskennen und hier ist diese
versorgungsforschungsförderung natürlich
jetzt eine große Chance weil sich jetzt
viele bewerben werden um diese Förderung
und dadurch auch die Möglichkeit besteht
dass viele neue Ambulanzen aufmachen und
wenn die dann ähm angefangen haben dann
hat man auch Zeit um in der Zwischenzeit
zu schauen wie diese in Zukunft weiter
finanziert werden können und da ist ähm
ja auch gerade der GBA beauftragt worden
hier Konzepte zu entwickeln die sollen
bis Ende des Jahres vorgelegt werden
auch wie man also diese Versorgung auch
adäquat finanzieren kann
zum Schluss noch auf jeden Fall ein paar
Fragen hier aus dem Stream ansehen und
zwar fasse ich da ein paar zusammen es
gab jetzt häufiger die Frage in die
Richtung warum gibt es erst seit der
Pandemie so viele Geschädigte gibt es da
ein Zusammenhang wie lässt sich das
erklären und auch die Frage ob eben das
vertiksyndrom von der Impfung her der
corona-impfung nehme ich an Herr rühren
kann
also es gab auch vor der Pandemie schon
viele Betroffene wir hatten Zahlen immer
geschätzt von etwa 300.000 Betroffenen
die sind jetzt auch bestätigt worden
durch die Kassenärztliche
Bundesvereinigung und jetzt in den
letzten ähm zwei bis drei Jahren sind
natürlich sehr viele Menschen an einer
schweren Infektion erkrankt die auch neu
war für unser Immunsystem und deswegen
ist es nicht überraschend dass diese
Infektion auch bei vielen mezfs
ausgelöst hat so dass wir davon ausgehen
dass wir inzwischen ungefähr doppelt so
viele Betroffene haben
die Betroffenen die natürlich jetzt nach
wie vor also stand jetzt in Deutschland
es schwer haben Hilfe zu finden daher
auch noch mal konkret die Frage an Sie
aus dem Stream bei YouTube habe ich
gesehen wann wird die Charité für
Menschen mit dem Syndrom geöffnet die
nicht in Berlin Brandenburg wohnen das
ist wohl ein Patient aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen ohne Anlaufstelle
plädiere dafür dass wir in Deutschland
überall
wohnortnahe Versorgungszentren haben es
macht überhaupt keinen Sinn dass wir
alle Patienten aus Deutschland in Berlin
sehen wir haben es hier nicht mit einer
seltenen sondern mit einer häufigen
Erkrankung zu tun und ich habe eben den
zweiten Teil Ihrer Frage noch nicht
beantwortet das möchte ich noch kurz
ergänzen die Frage war ob nach Impfung
auch im ecfs auftreten kann also ich
habe selbst einige Patienten gesehen die
das Vollbild von einem icfs nach einer
glaskow 2 Impfung entwickelt haben das
ist auch nicht verwunderlich denn auch
diese Impfungen am aktiviert natürlich
dass Immunsystem und Menschen die ähm
das Risiko in sich tragen so eine
Erkrankung zu entwickeln bei den kann
auch eine Impfung schon ausreichen das
soll aber jetzt kein Plädoyer gegen eine
Impfung sein ganz im Gegenteil denn die
Impfung macht das sehr sehr viel
seltener als die Infektion und es ist
anzunehmen vom Mechanismus her dass
diese Menschen durch eine Infektion
genauso dann an einem ecfs erkrankt
werden
das sagt Professor Dr Carmen
scheibenbogen ich möchte Ihnen hier auf
jeden Fall noch Lob von dem Stream
weitergeben bei Facebook schrieb Martina
Gregorius danke Frau Professor Dr
scheibenbogen dass sie sich seit Jahren
für uns einsetzen und wir sagen auf
vielen Dank dass Sie sich heute Zeit für
uns genommen haben die Leiterin des
vertikzentrums der Berliner Charité
vielen Dank sehr gerne
und auch dann kann euch natürlich wie
immer für eure Fragen und für eure
Kommentare ich habe hier auch noch zwei
gesehen jemand mit dem Namen La Isolde
schreibt eine fürchterliche Erkrankung
und zu wenig Forschung Medikamente und
Unterstützung dein anderer User mit dem
Namen Cristo bald bei Youtube es ist
verdammt wichtig das chronische
Infektionen untersucht werden man könnte
viel bessere Diagnostik machen
beziehungsweise behandeln damit möchte
ich enden und sage gerne bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss